what the [ __ ] is going on I like to
party Jesus honey this is unwaxed
with Sophia and Sistine Salon should we
just become best friends hello everybody
and welcome back to another episode of
the unwax podcast with your favorite Duo
sisters
BFFs
um enemies
Rivals my yang to my yang
the blonde to the brunette
maybe not forever the toilet paper to
the butt you're not going brunette
Sophia so I'm Sophia oh I'm Sistine I
feel like you guys know that by now
hopefully I know at this point I feel
like whoever's listening to this has
been listening you're not going brunette
because honestly I'm thinking about our
brand so we don't have Brands look we
don't have a brand but I think
hypothetically one day if we build a
brand it just looks better
fair fair but my hair is also falling
out so probably gonna go back to Natural
that sounds like a you problem that
sounds like a yeah it's a me problem so
my problem I'm going to solve just like
you did because your hair was falling
out actually you know what I did
yesterday yes
um I ordered clip-on bangs from Amazon
you and your bangs you've been saying
you gave me crap for the brown but bangs
are more risky I know that's why I
bought clip-ons so I'm like okay let's
let's test this out because either I
could look like Urkel or it could be
kind of cute I just see girls on
Instagram that have these really sick
bangs with the dark long hair I'm like
you know what's crazy though we're going
we're focusing on two things that
usually are as a result from a breakup
or a big life change so you're saying
I'm sad and hurting inside so I need to
change my appearance
we'll get into it later but I wanted to
well actually and I were talking about
this in the car yesterday and it was
kind of an awkward bring up
um about our podcast and the future of
unlocks and what's going on right now
and it was kind of funny because I both
think we had the same idea it's almost
like
you know when you break up with someone
and you or you're getting broken up with
and you just don't know how to address
it and when someone does you're like oh
geez I was thinking the same thing
totally and you just didn't want to
admit it to each other this podcast is
like dating we've had this for two plus
years this is the longest relationship
I've ever been in you have become now
just not even my work girlfriend you're
my work wife
you guys were getting a divorce
slightly all right we're on a break so
explain do you want to go into it yeah I
think okay so
maybe three episodes ago we
very vaguely explained why we went
missing for three months and just
stopped recording
you guys deserve a little bit more
clarity on that we were assigned to a
different podcast company which started
really great and I think that they did
an amazing job built our brand in ways
that I don't know we could have done
without their help yeah they gave
clothing and an image and stuff to our
show that didn't happen yeah we had a
set that was customized to us I mean we
had great guests coming out it was all
going no I would love to work working
with everyone but like most business
transactions it just fell apart in a way
that we weren't expecting and was pretty
sad because you know when you have
something that you start from the ground
up like Sophie and I did with this
podcast and we cherish it and we work
really hard on it and you bring people
in that sort of
I I guess I would say take advantage of
you and I think a lot of people can
relate to that in terms of
I guess any Department in their life but
in work life yeah I mean I think the
main thing was just creative differences
it's no hate to the previous company
that we were with but
the way that they went about their
business didn't exactly align with our
morals and our values and what we like
and how we choose to continue growing
the show so we left them and since then
Sophia and I have been in different
Studios everywhere just trying to bring
the show back to what it was and I feel
as if we've lost that momentum that we
had which is really yeah that's a key
word is the momentum because before it
was same Studio same Vibe and I think
that's why everyone loved it the guest
the consistency the consistency we had a
lot more help with like the growth that
we were getting
um and it felt good that we were finally
getting compensated for something that
we were working hard for because we were
doing for free for basically like a
whole year and a half and then now we're
back together
it's it's a combination of also the
podcast with the reality show and then
[ __ ] with our family and it's just
paused right and so now we're back and
we're trying really hard to kind of get
the ball rolling again but it really
isn't the same it doesn't have the same
touch I think what's hard is Sophie and
I are such perfectionists that we don't
want to produce or give you guys
anything that is half-assed yeah and
that is in 100 like we're fully
confident in the work that we're putting
out there and I love what we're saying
and how we're doing it but you know
we're editing Sophia's having tech
support calls at three in the morning
with Fireside trying to upload it to
Spotify I'm sorry guys if you're not
hearing um the podcast on Spotify or app
or seeing it it's not my fault I'm doing
it right this is the disaster Sophia's
like coding at two in the morning trying
to figure out I'm trying to like edit
this that we got locked out of every
account our YouTube our our Tick Tock I
mean we're trying so hard and I just try
to keep people because it's December I'm
like January New Year I know but with
that being said um I brought this up to
60 and she agreed so what we're thinking
for the next chapter chapter of full say
unwax season three maybe we might not
hit the 100th episode because if we do
the 100th episode we want it to be a
hundredth
and it's a big big celebration for us
too so what we're thinking about doing
is pausing for a bit again but actually
going into it and rebranding finding a
company that aligns with us and building
back what it was and then have a
consistent flow of guests and story
times and actually provide you with the
most quality content that you guys
deserve and that we actually expect I
think of the show I think a big part of
it too is we don't exactly have a home
base right now and it's pretty hard and
it's hard trying to produce a show and
be consistent in a studio that we don't
have anymore we're in Florida we're in
La so our plan is once we move to New
York in March
we will start up the show again at that
time studio consistency back to regular
programming it'll be like it was
but until then it's been fun this is
going to be our last one for a second
not the last forever but don't don't
don't lose hope don't let go of us
please we're not just saying that we are
that sneaky X that is coming back in a
few months later what was the toxicity
like hey happy New Year we're back here
so wait for that because we will be back
we'll keep all of our accounts and
socials running like we're we're still
gonna be active so yes and if you guys
need like personal unsolicited advice
let's transition to what
we did the other day so you guys know
that we've been shooting a reality show
with Paramount plus which has been
a long journey I mean we started filming
this last November yeah and it's still
being filmed but it's also been previous
from that we were filming it with
another Series yeah this is just so it's
been about three years honestly in the
making Sophia and I've been pitching to
every Network we've been hustling on the
show yeah we finally saw the 10 episodes
we saw the first season in Fall yeah
what was your first reaction to watching
yourself in that light I I didn't
realize how much I talk out of the side
of my mouth I was gonna say this my
mouth is so slanted damn it
gave us this paralyzed mouth I know it
just like the lopsided slanted it's so
lost and then it gets especially when I
get nervous or I'm trying to think of
something I start to do it more and I
get all quirky like like and it's so bad
that's this is the problem with watching
yourself I mean we should be used to
this by now since we do this literally
every week week with our show but when
you see it in that version it it's so
it's so weird and you honestly pick
yourself apart and because it's not like
an Instagram photo that you can face
tune and filter and make yourself look
perfect and it's not also a podcast
where you can kind of edit it up and
like right like put a nice for example
we'll be shooting a scene at 10 in the
morning and our hair looks great our
makeup is fresh and then we'll be
shooting another scene at eight o'clock
at night well we look tired and worn but
they use that eight o'clock scene yeah
and so you know you're like oh man I
look like crapola but something that I
noticed the most is there's a scene of
us at a diner oh I know this one and
actually we get into a bit of a coral we
we're fighting in this scene it's kind
of funny how long ago it was and I
literally forgot what the coral was I
know because we fight all the time yeah
I know um which one and I've really
gotta study these other TV personalities
the way that they work when a camera's
on because I genuinely just acted as if
there wasn't a camera I am
seriously inhaling not even breathing
scarfing a BLT like didn't even take
breaths between chews and then yeah but
every time they cut to me my mouth is
full like a chipmunk and then I start
eating a whole pickle I'm like why I
know I know and we we watch so much
reality TV where we see how people treat
food on TV and they don't eat it they
probably eat it when they go okay that's
a wrap at a dinner scene you don't see
them eating the people plate of pasta
pizza the pasta has like one I felt like
I had never had food in my mouth in my
life I was eating it like it was my last
time I know I know and then also I
noticed that I just I cry a lot and you
cry a lot and this is the thing I
actually don't I really uh you have a
good crying face though do I yeah thank
God you look pretty when you cry you
don't have an ugly cry oh God thank God
that was actually a worry of mine
because I can't tell because for me I'm
like okay that's how I look when I cry
but it's weird seeing it in real and you
know what it is it's more the pressure
and I don't think I I will cry but I
realized more as I get older I feel like
I am a crier now
don't you think like when I get
emotional about something I start to
tear up I just think when you get older
you got to release more [ __ ] that you
have yeah since you cry more that's
probably you know what it is true when I
was younger I was like I don't really
cry at sad movies or anything but now oh
my God the biggest Rolex that I had when
I was younger was I would I don't know
why I would brag about this on the
middle school yard be like
I didn't cry during Marley and Me
like it's so strong so I never cried
either I was like yeah a really tough
girl there's so many random things that
you brag about when you're younger
because I remember like I brag about the
fact that I've never had Chinese takeout
people think that's insane you still
have never had Chinese takeout no I'm
just saying I never have had that
is that weird and then they say that as
a flex but it's really not a flex it's
kind of a sad thing that I haven't
occurred yes you haven't like lived and
had a fun drunk night and no have you
yes oh God where have I been
regardless I think that
also it's the show is not I feel like
people when they hear reality show they
put such a bad stigma on it right I
think everyone's assuming oh it's drama
it's fake it's fighting but the way that
it's shot I've never and we've seen
everything exclusive right now it's
nothing like it yeah when I say nothing
I mean polar Ops and I was saying this
people I'm like it's more like a
docu-series of our family yeah it's not
it's not raunchy it's not there's no
like there's drama but there's not like
it you get to have an inside look into
like what's going on in our lives like
how we usually are and um but yeah that
that also just is that was a different
world it's cool I like it I'm really
excited about it I think
I could argue that maybe do you think
I'm the most excited out of you guys to
film yeah I love this girl and I think
probably you are no you love it but you
but we've been like I think we've had
our moments yeah I want like another
season like I want to keep going I just
I don't know what it is when a camera
zombie I'm like show tunes like I want
to perform that's what the problem is
dad told me because
I said to him I feel like they're not
even in the room like it you guys are
literally watching us at our dinner
table right and we turn our heads and
there's 10 cameramen behind us yeah I
don't even notice them anymore and he
said that's when it gets dangerous
that's why and you you think oh how do
people not know that they're miked up
and they like release on the show and
they don't you really don't remember
yeah when you're wearing like a pot box
on your back for seven months and a
little fuzzy thing on your chest you
don't even realize it it feels like your
own clothing yeah and that's where it
gets dangerous and then you realize oh
[ __ ] I hope that doesn't get to the
final cut or I'm just excited for people
to see I'm finding like release it
that's the thing I actually am very
excited about this truly as stressful
and chaotic yeah as it's been it's
almost one of those things like I'm
ready for it to just be out there and as
sad as this is I know we're gonna get
trolls and people are gonna make fun of
us about the way we look and then our
slanted mouth and let me just tell you
guys something I've already told myself
all the things that you could possibly
so please keep it to yourself because I
say it to myself all the time anyway so
you're your biggest should we talk about
Sophia actually yesterday
you give me the weirdest FaceTime call
yes it's so weird you were so flustered
you out I had to like test out the
waters because
we you know we always talk about gifts
on the show and I I think everyone knows
I love to give experiences and this year
though separately I have a question what
do you think experiences are kind of a
cop-out
I I'm so insulted that you said that
because I literally gave you the option
of no no but I'm sorry I had an idea for
like or an experience do you think it's
harder to book an experience or to find
someone a gift
I think it depends because I think
experiences can be pretty pricey like I
love your experience
we're like really expensive Pretty Woman
the musical was a blast especially when
We snuck out first of all we went to a
really fun dinner and then we went and
then we left during the halftime or half
what's it called the uh intermission
like a football game Super Bowl I mean
it kind of is like a Super Bowl game but
no um I I don't think it's a cop-out I
think it's more fun I'm but I'm one of
those people I would rather have an
experience than
another like a bag you know so she calls
me and she goes this experience is
really weird and I don't know if you're
gonna like it but it's weird and I go
can you just tell me what I need to wear
no I'm like is it rated R no is it scary
no I'm like then what the hell is this I
can't because I don't if I say yes to
any of those because it could be it's my
most ambitious gift yet and when I hit
me at night this is like 10 o'clock at
night punched me sucker I was like this
is what she's been dying to do for so is
it a magic mic I cannot tell you is it
is it a magic mic is it a Magic Mike
show I'm not telling you anything then
you don't know me I am lock and key
because I would always ruin it for you
and stop asking me questions because you
know that one day I'm gonna slip up and
say stop asking me that like how did you
know I can argue but I think I got you
the most
sentimental thought out gift that I've
ever given anything
yeah it was mine but ours would be very
different can I say if you actually
don't shed a tear Christmas morning when
you unwrap my gift
I will be so pissed I'll honestly I'm
gonna throw my hands up and say nothing
I give you whether it's a porta potty or
this sentimental gift will ever please
you so I'm never gonna gift you again
this gift you'll never forget in your
entire life let's just say oh my God
you're going to explore a side of
yourself you've never explored I got
Scarlett actually such cute things like
I I'm so excited for you to get those
but
actually you know why I can bring her if
she's in town to the experience with us
if she wanted to join okay when is the
experience can you at least tell me that
it's next month
I'm not saying anything else what day
next month I'm not telling you anything
else [ __ ] because I could Google it yeah
all right fine fine I'm excited though
I'm really excited oh I'm gonna lose my
mind I have to like get everything set I
also argue that Sophia likes experiences
like gifting them because she could do
the cool thing too what this is what's
so annoying she says that but then I
asked her on the side like do you want
she goes yeah I love your experiences
Sofia I was like no you like them so
much stop it stop it that's not why you
like guns put your finger back in my
face you're so annoying she switches
characters faster than I can spin my
head around she literally said that you
liked experiences because it's like a
tradition now and you actually enjoy
them because they're funny stories
that's true honestly I enjoy them to
bring them back to the podcast don't
make it seem like it's for me I'm not
gifting myself I thought this very
through this is the most sentimental
gift I've ever given you I hope it's
something like really
kinky and weird it's crazy okay I'm
excited what I'm gonna say oh my God I
love that you wrote this down this just
gave me a huge throwback it's nostalgic
this next topic up winter we literally I
think to the year to this day yeah we
released an episode called wifed up one
time yeah I did pretty well actually
were we both single at that time yeah
yeah I remember we were both oh wait no
you weren't last year
I wasn't you were not I was
oh how the tables are turned reversed my
God
dang that's sad you know what I'm loving
though right now on Tick Tock is that
Trend that's like I need a big boy and
everyone it's cuffing season and now
finally the men that I like it's their
time to shine a big boy I love it no but
I like just a guy that isn't in shape
like a dad bod all the girls are liking
them now I'm like finally give them
attention we've had short Kings you
should make it you should make a thirst
trap
of who you should just make a tick tock
of myself no of the guys you think are
cute like a little compilation video
why would I do that and humiliate myself
why would I post a bunches so much
seriously
who do you think takes like the big boy
Crown just Jason Momoa that's it yeah
but someone argue he's not a big boy
because he's kind of Rich what are you
he's a big boy are you kidding what I'm
loving is the who's the dad from
stranger things
oh yeah that's a big boy okay yeah
that's yeah that is but I think extra
cozy by the fireplace extra warmth you
would you're like you love you love Dad
bods just look like a bear so she just
saw the topic of men
um we went to dinner with
because I hate them I'm just kidding I
like I like some of you guys
um not the ones that are mean to me
though
being single I forgot how
uh
how little tricksters these men are out
there we actually had a really good
dinner conversation I wish that was
recorded yeah last night because we're
just talking about relationships and
dating and for example this guy's
reaching out to me and planned to date
and I was sort of on edge I was like I'm
not sure didn't say yes
he has a girlfriend
full girlfriend that is just hidden off
of everything yeah and I'm like see but
why do why why you know I don't know I
do that but out of respect for her it's
like why do that I feel like I don't
know if it's lately just because of
social media and the
the ease of how men can like or even
women too dude can like find thirst
traps I'll tell you this
what the hell is Ghost mode on Instagram
and why are people using it do you know
what ghost mode is there's a ghost mode
oh yeah what's a ghost mode oh yeah it's
basically Snapchat and Instagram you
know when you send someone a DM yeah and
it stays there and sometimes you can
unsend it yeah just so forewarning to
anyone out there listening if someone
messages you on Instagram in vanish mode
Sophia after you leave the app the whole
message deletes like Snapchat like the
conversation's gone why are they making
it easier to like if you can't text me
and then have it on the files in the
iCloud for life then I don't want it
here's my new favorite thing yeah guys
do this is my favorite
little sneaky men out there let me show
you this account that I
my guy friend showed me and I just said
this is so funny and genius at the same
time yourself a favor guys and Google
puppy melons on Instagram also my
favorite part is go to Mutual to see who
out of your phone yeah see which one of
your friends or your exes or your
girlfriends follow this account so to
the naked eye just a very innocent dog
Instagram full of dog pictures go ahead
and click on one of the dog photos
swipe
text
tits ass every single picture so let me
tell you whoever this genius is
disguised as a cute puppy page so when
your girl sees it oh my boyfriend is
following a dog account no the whole
thing is tit's ass and the hottest girls
I've ever seen in my life so funny
because last time we also checked out of
sistine's following like who follows it
and he it made me lose my mind I know
who you are and also that's not that's
not just one there's a ton of them I
have to say points for creativity yeah
really I mean I would have never thought
that if I didn't like chat we should
make one for cats and then have dudes I
guarantee there's already one for cats
and giraffes and elephants and
everything in between I know we should
make one but I just thought it was so
funny so if your boyfriend says I really
love lizards and there's just like a
whole lizard picture like why would I
ever follow Elizabeth's swipe and
probably a bunch of snakes if you know
what I mean you never know you never
that's actually a pretty good one you
never know
but going back to wifed up winter you're
wifed up
is Scarlet
I don't even know
should we ask her
Scarlet Stallone get in here yeah we
surprised you guys
Stallone's in the studio today to
explain yourself lady explain yourself
you look very chic yeah you're giving
like Haley Bieber meets Steve Jobs right
now with the little blazer Scarlett
thank you so much for coming in we have
a lot of questions for you you have a
lot of explaining to do yeah loving your
Miami life I do really like it I'd like
to
ask the question again wifed up winter
um what kind of sucks about my wifed up
winter is that
um I wouldn't say I'm in a relationship
right now okay not really
you know there's so many dating steps
there's so many why are they you know I
want to talk about that I want to talk
about that that's something that I never
really understood about dating
especially in the US because that why is
there five steps there should be the
talking they're talking then there's the
um casually dating each other you know
kids in college go snapping snapping
that's what that's what I've not I don't
like that stage and I've never even
encouraged myself to do that but I don't
even use Snapchat that stage as if
you're
it's so casual that you won't even
message yeah it's literally Sophia it is
literally snapping you just snap photos
to each other I see my girl no no I know
and it's so weird because I see my
girlfriends and they're like oh yeah I'm
talking to a new guy and they would show
me I go oh what do you guys would show
me like what's the tax like show me the
details show me the messages
she opens a snap from the guy it is a
saline in his forehead a piece of hair
from him and I'm I'm thinking to myself
that that's your talking I guess there
is a lot more levels than I thought I
thought it was just talking exclusive
relationship like boyfriend girlfriend I
was just so confused because what stage
are you at
she's like I don't even know oh there's
there's one two three four five there's
oh then there's the there's there's
talking and then there's exclusive I
think you're exclusive I I am yes I am
exclusive congratulations she is wiped
out before the winter what does that
even mean it means you found a good lad
a good egg listen I imagine he's a good
egg yeah he's a good egg I met this kid
when I was in Miami actually the way
that I met him was so funny
oh yeah explain so I'm in this very cool
restaurant bar I showed her one of my
favorite restaurants yeah so fun I'm all
dressed up I'm with Scarlett and he's
coming and so we were sort of just like
waiting to the side obviously I'm at the
bar getting a drink because my anxiety
is out of 10 and I'm trying to loosen up
and I see this adorable kid walk in and
just beeline it to me yeah and I was
like
oh my God I think that's what I have to
respect about it that's what I I didn't
even have to tell the kid look you have
to impress my sisters or anything
because I wanted it I wanted to test it
he comes straight to me and immediately
I thought check
Ernie points in the fam made an effort I
was looking around for him and I go
where where's Sistine and where he told
me he was going to be here they're
talking in the corner but they're not
okay it may sound like weird to everyone
no they're not flirting in the corner no
no I'm not even insinuating that I'm not
even sitting there but he quickly went
to Scarlett so there I am sort of like
left alone to the side yeah uh the only
person giving me male attention was this
very older very very very older
gentleman named Jeff Jeff you're
watching what's up
Jeff at the bar
um we're gonna call him Jeff at the bar
so Jeff the bar he's like can I buy you
a drink I go Jeff I'm I'm drinking once
he's wearing some really cool
button-down shirt and he was just very
attached to steam for some reason I
don't know what I'll tell you what the
red flag was his screensaver was a photo
of two of his kids that were easily my
age and I was like listen buddy but
honestly at the same time we will have a
great conversation he was telling me all
about his ex-wife how they vacation
together and I'm but I'm like enjoying
there's no there was no sexual tension
between the two um hold on I was feeling
Jeff what I'm just kidding yeah
absolutely but on your end I no but I
can tell that I was looking to the side
where I'm trying to have a good time we
are in Miami
dancing on the table and I'm looking
while I'm on the the surface level while
I'm literally dancing on the tables I
look over and I'm like where is my
sister she is having a full-on eye to
eye conversation with this Jeff listen
we were we were very deep in his divorce
and we were talking about he went there
for therapy
I did not bring you to Miami to have a
life to life talk but I'll talk
this is what was super weird so Jeff was
easily
55 60 maybe I know it sounds really
that's like sounds weird like you know
Jeff is also living his best life like I
give props to the guy you know age is
just the number and uh so I'm at the bar
with Jeff we're just hanging out
and obviously he sees
your guy and like all of his friends and
you know his ego was shot because
there's a bunch of cute young men in
there now and he's like oh man so you
know what Jeff did the nerve on this guy
this was insane Jeff
asks for a pen
and he slips me a note and I'm thinking
and he's leaving so he slips me and out
and leaves and I think oh it's his phone
number right yeah it's not a game of
tic-tac-toe it's just his phone number
and
I open it and it says 49 days
like what and I go Jeff what does this
mean
and he goes That's how long I predict
your sister's relationship with this guy
to last
the nervous
I know what are you a genie what I mean
that's a ball that's kind of rude
because just because Otto are you
[ __ ] on him or is it no I think he
just got maybe jealous that like all
these young boys just sort of came in
and took us away but it was so funny
in my counter I have a it marked the 49
days yeah
I was back to let you guys know
yeah let us know if Jeff was right yeah
just goes into clubs and predicts
people's relationships I know two days
but I do want to get into since we're on
the topic of Miami you're now a
sophomore in college yeah you're almost
done with your sophomore which is crazy
so weird and I was telling by so fast
and I was telling Sofia I feel like
every time you come on our show one you
look older you're more mature really I
look older completely yeah completely
and we just get a new science it's funny
that she thinks that's a compliment if
anyone said I looked older I'd be pissed
you look younger God like you are
Benjamin yeah you don't you don't age
thank God but the last time you were on
the show you had all these updates you
said you know for rushing you said you
don't want to rush yeah you said that
freshman year was really hard for you
friendship adjusting to the new location
give us a little update how is we'll
start with just living in Miami in your
apartment how's that been
um so as you know if you listen to that
podcast of when I tell talked about
Miami when I first lived there I had no
idea how to navigate that City I'd know
I was just a lost puppy in a city to be
quite honest with you yeah yeah it was
scary I was so not adjusted because
living in L.A
could you not you you stay home you
don't go out you live in a bubble you
have your same friends you have your
same routine every day with your parents
and you live with your parents and then
moving across the country to this place
where I'd I felt like I did not fit in
but then I realized the reason why I'm
not fitting is because I'm not letting
myself adjust I am not letting myself
you know
I'm here and I'm not gonna leave so
might as well just make the most of it
and actually change and change my
mindset change how I view things change
how I view the city and because at first
I go I don't like it here I don't like
the people I don't so negative and
that's really that's it yeah people
always ask in and write you know how do
I push myself to be more social and go
out there because you're the perfect
example of someone that can go full
hermit and isolate or be extremely
social make a ton of friends because I
know that your freshman year you know
you sort of struggle to find your
footing find your friendships and now
it's like you're a complete social
butterfly so what did you do well you
have to look at your surroundings and
think to yourself you know I'm alone
because I made myself alone and I am
going to try my best to you know
actually actually if you if you think
about it I I met so many amazing people
freshman year that I didn't try for that
friendship you know like friendships are
relationships they're they're literally
if you don't actually put in the effort
and if you don't text them like hey what
are you doing I was always that person
that was so off my face I never wanted
to reach out to friends I never wanted
to like it's not like I didn't want to
but I just think I didn't need a try
because they're they're just girlfriends
or whatnot but then I realized you know
I met so many amazing girls and now I
have all my best girlfriends since I've
had I've had since freshman year because
I put in the effort yeah and they put an
effort just as much I always say give it
a year for whatever give it a year and
then and go out of your comfort zone
like I was so I was kind of like you at
first when I when we first go when I
first moved to Miami I was so scared of
like dressing a certain way I was so
scared but then I go what's the harm in
try
what's the worst that can happen I'm
wearing something crazy out and I loved
it right I was so I was so scared to
leave it it's such a it's such a vibrant
energy and it's such a rush too when you
realize that you were changing I
honestly I feel like Sophie and I are
watching so much change off anything
right before our eyes like I still look
at you like a 10 year old that's super
Goofy and wearing her basketball shorts
and it's so hard for me to wrap my head
around that you're a mature grown ass
adult and I can have adult conversations
with you and go out with you and go to
drag shows end up at Drag Brunch
together accidentally and you guys are
going on a date this weekend too yeah
should we talk about that you guys yeah
I'm a little stressed out and thank God
I recruited Scarlet because you know I'm
single I've recruited Scarlett said will
you be my date because I'm going to
Harry Potter world you are yeah that's
why I can't go I know
what it's so fun oh I'll go again I'm
gonna get a wand I'm gonna get butter
beer okay and I want my own like because
I know it's delicious I'll FaceTime you
when I'm drinking and I'll tell you how
it is I'm going during sunset I'll tell
you this when I went to Harry Potter
World
you truly felt like you were in the film
it is the most realistic thing you've
ever seen
my next phase is going to Harry Potter
World in Orlando yeah apparently that's
way bigger and she was waiting police
we've always wanted to go on a trip with
all three of us
like theme parks but Orlando's so big on
so many things like we might have to
sleep there and then wake up and like
rally again Sophia we are 100 sleeping
at the amusement park thank God we are
going to sleep with Harry okay yeah so
you're going to Harry Potter yeah I'm
stoked I got an invitation don't know
how to a very glamorous Hollywood
Premiere it's the movie with Margot
Robbie it looks amazing do you want to
go see Babylon and like go to this
really cool Hollywood Premiere I'm like
no I'm gonna be at the Sorting Hat so
you can take whatever you want so I said
Scarlett please will you be my date
because I can't do these things alone
and she of course of course said yes
said yes yes absolutely so we are like
I don't want to say we're cheap or lazy
maybe we're both but when you go to
events like this influencers actors
everyone that attends they are dressed
to the nines yeah hair and makeup which
isn't cheap by the way and then you buy
a brand new gown which obviously isn't
cheap and I was like Scarlett should we
just do it with the Walmart version
we'll do our own hair and makeup and
maybe just find something in our closet
to wear let's just go hot damn crowd and
then leave and then just say we went so
what our plan is because I emailed the
lady I said what is the attire and it's
full gown
that doesn't happen often I know and I I
wish I kind of prepared for this yeah
earlier I know I wanted to wear like a
feather scarf and a hat these two are
types of whoever they knew that has the
same body so this is you have a long
floor this is what I thought Scarlet's
like what do we wear I don't have a
dress and I go oh Scarlett I wore this
beautiful dress to a wedding a few
months ago you can wear that so she's
wearing my old wedding dress I'm wearing
because I've already promised her she
could wear the better one because it's
stunning I'm wearing my old prom dress
from high school when I was 18. and by
the way then I wore it that's my friend
now it's gonna go back to this dress is
easily nine years old dresses yeah but
like I'm showing up an old prom dress
good sometimes things are like classic
Timeless pieces
no it's not it is time it's not Timeless
it's tattered Scarlet ruins the edge of
it like the bottom what the hell did you
do at the prom
she danced too much it's ripped I have
no idea yeah wedding dress to your
promise
that was so bad don't even understand
I'm actually the thing is I gotta really
go through my camera world you know
what's sad is that everything I do when
it comes to getting ready is backwards I
never dress you always miss the black
everything
you're going for but here's the mark you
just stepped over I just every every
time I get to the garage I see these two
I'm like [ __ ] missed the Mark again
just out of it like they can't do it I'm
on I get you don't worry that's why I'm
wearing literally Sophia I think I'll go
back to you your problem is you have
your Seasons mixed up yeah so you dress
for summer in the winter and then you
dress for winter in the summer it's true
that is actually true we went to a very
formal Christmas party and you were what
could have been a beach cover oh my God
a beach cover-up so a little nicer than
Beach cover-up but yes it was Sofia it
was a tiny white spaghetti strap dress
but anyway I'm very nervous about this
party you guys will see it on Instagram
if you follow us I don't know I'm
wearing a prom dress that's old it
probably still I don't know if we've
even washed it
yeah oh [ __ ] I know it's gonna smell
like very old vanilla
very old Charlotte said they'll be like
no it's gonna smell like old fake tan
I remember okay dirt this is so random
but at my prom Sistine we're in we're in
such a rush to get hair makeup done
everything and we had no time to self
tan and see it self tan one of my legs
[Applause]
you look so tan and golden I go yeah I
just I just tanned before this not self
tan I don't want to tell people that I
self tanned
we were standing outside and you know
that blue you know when the sun Just
Hits different and it's very blue like
bad lighting on you so I walk in I'm
looking at my skin I'm like oh my gosh I
look like The Annoying Orange it's just
and every time I walked the other bright
snowflake of a leg walks out with it
I looked like no can I just say the most
humbling thing I just had with the
tanning experience that happened like
for because it's Christmas party so that
dress only shows this up here right and
this down here so I was like I guess I
don't need to tear in my tummy the shoe
guys when you're orange pale orange I'm
just telling you you will never feel
worse you look like a clown fish you
were striped so I was like oh because
tanning takes out like at least like
five pounds off here that's why people
do it like we look 10 times better we
look hotter we feel good so I love
living mine I literally like I was
trying on bathing suits because I'm
going to like I'm going out of town soon
and I'm going to be at a beach I'm like
I mean try on some things before I go
and I forgot that I didn't tear my tummy
and it was so bad everything I know
bathing suit just looked like I thought
it's fine you know what I'm gonna tan
only one of my legs in this prom dress
just to you're not gonna want to sustain
I'm telling you when I say I was holding
my dress the whole prom I was running to
the bathroom non-stop I was literally
waiting damn I really gotta wash this
dress I looked like a deli sandwich it
was just not good okay we should play
which sister game you guys we became
famous as sisters not because of
anything else but Scarlett's old YouTube
channel and the best video that ever
come out of that YouTube channel was one
video called witch sister because this
girl had some cute Vlogs
but which sister went viral but this is
a thing this is Scarlett deleted it but
someone everything I swiped the plate
off that some genius redid it and
brought it back it has 700
167 000 views I kind of say when
Scarlett had hers up it was what five
million views it was like crazy which we
were really really really confused about
oh is her still there yeah oh we looked
so crusty five years ago I don't I
thought it looked really cute I don't
know it is so bad anyway we we made this
video five years ago when Scarlett was
an aspiring YouTuber yeah and it blew up
so we thought let's do a mini version
okay we asked just spicy questions and
we asked each other who would be the
most likely to do it all right let's
just take it away okay I'll read the
first one which sister is the worst liar
you I think I am I'm a great liar I'm
really bad now how good I I'm really
good I'll tell you the secret it's not a
good thing to brag about only if it only
if it is not hurting anyone the secret
to being a good liar is being very
specific with details like down to the
detail the more detailed you are the
more realistic it is yeah you just have
a better your poker face I don't have a
kid she's a poker face and she has a
really good memory so when you're in a
fight with her she'll remember
everything but it's also yeah even if
you get factual and stuff you're still
able to twist and then make it to your
favorite and then I would think to
myself did I say it yeah exactly huh
like she actually can you put words in
their mouth
a little bit okay cool which sister
picks the best guys
I think I do
I think we both do I think I have a
really good taste I think you and I
everybody
I'll say the last place is definitely
this one right here my last relationship
my last relationship was the best action
Apple in the book Yes actually I do have
to her last boyfriend was great the
other ones the other one's rotten not
not no why not I would say oh your high
school boyfriend you both had like
you had a really great boyfriend and you
have had a really great boyfriend your
current boyfriend's really great I've
only had three and I think they fall
back about three x's and they're both
great okay so you guys tie on that one
yeah good job Scarlett yeah damn it um I
know I know learn I messed up take notes
it to us it's so hard to build a
relationship with a guy when they only
message me in vanish mode I'm trying
here this is snapping okay
which sister has oh this is so easy the
sharpest tongue
I think both of you guys are because
both of you guys are very sensitive
people so
um you guys get very Snappy you're
actually pretty sharp too when you get
yeah yeah you get scary you get shots
no Scarlett doesn't get like outwardly
sharp like we are she's sharp under her
breath yeah so then you'll hear a little
comment like what'd you say the whole
time she's like this like like she'll
look around and it pisses you off more
because she doesn't say anything yeah
exactly I do it under my bra pretty he's
like I'm so angry okay which sister is
going to be the best MILF are you saying
that we'd all be Mouse no the hottest
mouth or just a MILF oh just a mouth
like who do you think is gonna be just
the best smell me I think because you
guys are gonna Age first
that's not fair but what constitutes a
MILF I feel like so physically because
spiritually no I feel like Sophia would
and I would just give this one to her
because for years she's been saying all
I want to be when I grow up is a Mill
and so I feel like she's been preparing
for this there's a couple there's a
couple really inspiring dreams I have in
one of them old and like fat and not
care about anything and get gray and
chain smoke no I want to have a six-pack
and like be like Mom like Mom's my mom's
a MILF she she can do wakeboarding she's
an alien dude she's an alien yeah she's
really Sophia MILF winner thank you I'm
I'll take it I'll give it I'll run the
last one is which sister could get away
with murder for sure not me if y'all
don't think this is me then for sure not
me
see you just gave a sharp tongue with
your eyes what was that you don't think
I could get away with murder
you think you could you're the you would
leave your fingerprints everywhere you
would you know what you would do is
called you would have the like weapon in
your back pocket but you wouldn't look
both ways from when you cross the street
and you'd get hit by a car that's just
like you know it would be like she would
be thinking about the murder and then
not realize that she's Crossing no
Scarlet would do the murder actually do
such a messy job and then call us and be
like what do I do how do I clean this up
I think I would
get out of here
you guys know it's me come on I've been
saying the way I'd get away with murder
for years now that's true okay yeah okay
so steam one how to kill someone
I'll give you that one I'll be the
hottest MILF you'll be the easiest color
that's like such the generic one okay so
since we're gonna wrap this episode up
and we were just saying before in the
beginning that this is going to be the
last one for a second not forever and
I'm really glad Scott could be here for
you no we won't be here for the New
Years so I think it would be really
special just to give one one sentence or
one thing that you want in the New Year
your New Year's resolution or something
you're working towards something that
you want to happen man I really want to
dye my hair red so you're that's your
New Year's resolution
I mean deeper come on
she goes I want to be around yeah I'm
like this is our last time what's one
thing you're aspiring to me a redhead
okay that's yours I guess
I want to redo
I want to next year
fight for myself like be positive that's
my biggest goal I watched this video on
Tick Tock and I think it was from a
movie and the person was just saying
like who else is gonna fight for you
other than you and I was just thinking
about them like there's a lot of [ __ ]
that happened this last year and also
like a lot of criticism we watch
ourselves on this it's just like
constantly I feel like we doubt our
abilities and I don't want to doubt my
abilities anymore and I want to be like
my cheerleader my like I'm my only
person
[Laughter]
so mine is to be my my best friend like
I really want to do this I want to be
the treat myself the best I can yes yeah
okay I would say
I mean I totally agree with yours
because I feel like we work hard for a
lot of things and then we're right at
the point of them coming into fruition
and they're just like right there so I
guess my two parties
um to finally produce the movie that
I've been working on for four years now
I would love to see yeah
but I would say the main one is to feel
really good in my own skin yeah because
I always look in the mirror and find
what's wrong with myself instead of what
I like about myself yeah I don't like
that I do that right because it's not
getting much better you know we're
getting older every day well it's also
you guys we're we're our only selves
like we wake up with it ourselves we go
to bed with ourselves like we make the
decisions for ourselves every day treat
it like that it kind of almost
disassociate from your body and I also
think what can I do just just practicing
it every day even if you're not
confident like I want to pretend like I
am so then I truly just believe that I
am right so I think I would like that so
Sistine wants to see yourself like be
positive and treat yourself better I
want to be a fighter for myself in
school to be a redhead okay okay yeah I
didn't know we were going to see you
guys
okay I really want to
um purely surround myself with people
that make me happy and not try for
relationships that I know are not going
to benefit me it's your already found
that no Chef the resolution happened
already
honestly this year has changed me a lot
so I think it's aged me I also I want to
I want to do more and I I don't know if
that makes a lot of sense to anyone but
I want to do more in my life that will
make me really proud of myself and make
start doing things that
um just make me overall happy and I love
it yeah starting I've already started
I've already started that a little bit
but I want to actually be like I'm very
proud of you Scarlett yeah exactly yes
so the first thing you got to do is call
the Hair Salon step one step one no one
else is going to do it for you so you
better just do it yourself exactly this
is making me pretty sad actually
[Music]
we're not gonna see you guys for a while
so we love you we thank you we will be
back very soon
and we'll see you next Tuesday in March
we love you bye
[Music]